carnivores cinnamon rolls do exist
carnivore cinnamon rolls I mean even
though cinnamon doesn't come from an
animal and I'm pretty sure it's against
The Unofficial carnivore rules to eat
powdered egg whites instead of whole
eggs but I feel like this just goes to
show how stupid these diet labels truly
are these are not carnivore cinnamon
rolls this is a low carb low-calorie
high protein cinnamon egg white omelette
it's only carnivore to this crater
because allegedly that's the diet she's
now on like to all of you guys this
could be weight loss cinnamon rolls or
to me this could be like torture
cinnamon rolls what's in a name right
and I'm here for the creativity and like
the stealthy swaps and hacks but if your
diet is so strict that you're defining
like 40 calories worth of egg whites as
dessert it's probably not a healthy diet